Jim Lampley HBO's boxing host and a host
of the fight game which in Lampley the
replay of Canelo and triple G Saturday
at 1005 Eastern and Pacific than
available on HBO go and HBO now Jim
joins us now good morning Jim how are
you I'm all right
how are you Dan I'm doing okay if I
didn't see the fight on Saturday night
how would you sum it up well it's a
great fight it was a better fight than
the fight which preceded it a year ago
and that was a fight that you know that
a lot of acclaim and a lot of attention
for sustained intensity and technical
brilliance and this is a better fight
both guys went to a higher level and and
it's a tremendously difficult fight to
score every every round is close and
we've already seen how their styles
converged in in such a way that both
guys get a chance to show what they can
do and there's you know a high degree of
disagreement among fans and ringside
media experts etc etc as to who is
actually the winner just as well as the
case a year ago when it was a draw and
so there's a lot to see there it's the
kind of fight that serious intense
devoted boxing fans will watch several
times as the years go by because this
it's very memorable combat between two
tremendously important fighters who have
brought a lot to the sport and
[Music]
and one of them I think will continue to
bring a lot to the sport for for a while
still yet to come I'm not sure about
Gennady golovkin at 36 he's pushing the
envelope but when he put on a brilliant
comeback in
the closing rounds of the fight the
other night after having seemed to fall
behind in the first half of the fight
and and made it very very difficult to
determine at the end who exactly was the
winner two judges gave 12th round to
Canelo that's what created the Canelo
win and and I'm curious about that I'm
gonna have to look back at the fight
again myself to to try to figure out how
to judges gave the 12th round to
golovkin or excuse me to Canelo when it
appeared to be just you know calling the
fight that that probably clunking was
the winner of the 12th round if those
judges give the 12th round to golovkin
instead of Canelo it would have been a
draw and I just have an instinctive
sense that a draw might have been the
right result this time just as the draw
was the result a year ago they debated
in such a way that it's just really hard
to choose who has gotten the better of
the other guy did the judges talk after
these things the judges talked to each
other after the fight no to the media I
don't know they don't talk to media and
Nevada State Athletic Commission is very
strict about not wanting judges to talk
to media so they they try to bottle that
as much as they can and yeah now I don't
know if anybody who spoke into one of
these judges in the wake of the flack I
know that there's always conspiracy
theories and we look at you know follow
the money in boxing and you can throw in
these things that you know are
time-tested here if I look at Canelo
Alvarez and triple G as you mentioned
the future of the sport then its Canelo
Alvarez more than it is triple G I don't
know what factors in with this gym but
you were there I think you said you said
something about you'd have to be Looney
Tunes to think that you know somebody
could score at 118 to 110 in the first
match between these two did you see
something that you would say I know who
won that fight after they
second fight no I don't think I would
have to look back with this fight and I
think I'm gonna have to look at it more
than once to really give you a strong
inclination as you won the fight but I
mean again to make the point styles
converge in an amazingly sort of natural
way that that creates the opportunity
for these constant surges of momentum
back in court you know one guy dominates
for 15 or 20 seconds and then the other
guy comes back and and you wind up with
exceptionally close very difficult to
score rounds that's point one point two
and I've made this point many many times
in public the average guy sits at home
on the sofa and and looks at a fight and
says to himself well you know this isn't
difficult I can score fight see it's not
an enterprise that very challenging I
think I know who wins who loses I can
make these choices that that's a myth
it's not that easy
it's an exceptionally difficult job it's
a subjective enterprise I mean there's a
reason why there are three judges and
they sit at three different spots around
the Ring the authorities who run the
sport are attempting in every way they
can to sort of balance out human error
because this is an enterprise that is
inherently subject to human error and
you know to everybody who says to me
other judges are terrible you know and
and I I know I could do better etc I
always say okay turn off the volume let
me let's see if we can get to a clean
video feed where there are no graphics
whatsoever you don't get copy box you
don't get Harold Letterman you don't get
replays you don't get all of the aides
that the home viewer has in watching and
evaluating the fight you sit there with
your naked eye and watch what happens
between two guys in the ring sometimes
you're blocked by the referee
sometimes you're blocked because action
takes place on the other side of the
Ring and a fighter has is back to you
while he's actually doing great work
that you can't actually see from the
angle at which you're sitting and then
one round is over you've got two seconds
to write down a name on a slip of paper
and handed to the referee who's coming
by to get it so you know people make
mistakes and and it's very easy to do so
in that enterprise and yes I thought the
Adelaide bird 118 but the 110 score card
a year ago was preposterous
it was an atrocity and and so of course
you know she wasn't a part of the panel
the other night and I'm not sure when
we'll see her judging a big fight again
but when you get down to you know
whether they're Canelo won six rounds or
seven whether body has won the last
three or four rounds in a row and and
judges are are trying to choose in a
very very subjective fine margin
situation and another thing I'll say is
a lot of people think that the margins
and competition in boxing are why they
aren't the margins of competition in
boxing are pretty much like the margins
of competition in tennis they're very
good and and you know what happens in
tennis and in boxing is two competitors
coming to the ring they face each other
face to face and eventually one guy
finds that there's there's a weakness
there's something that he can exploit
and the other guy and he goes back to
that weakness over and over and over and
over and eventually you see what you
think is a wide margin the competition
there are big differences between these
guys this guy's really good and he's so
much better it isn't not necessarily the
case that that's overall true it means
that he found the one thing that's
working that night and he can repeat it
and repeat it and repeat it in such a
way that he creates a big competitive
yet but it isn't really a large
competitive gap the
they work very very hard all their lives
they protect the craft that's extremely
difficult and at the end of the day they
know what they're doing so face to face
sometimes only the fighters really know
what I you know I'm not even sure that
Canelo Alvarez organized Lumpkin could
tell you with complete certainty in
their minds who won the other time they
know that there's not much difference
between them talking to Jim Lampley HBO
Sports when's the last time somebody
called you dan Patrick it's been a while
I always point out to people that you
are way taller than me and I think
considerably younger although I don't
know you might be catching me
I'm 62 are you lying on your a out there
nice topic you're still you're still
going to have to go for a few years I
think you may eventually get to me but
at the moment I am still ahead of you on
the age léger yes you're ahead on all
cards right now I do get that I have
gotten that several times fact I don't
even know if you know this but at one
point I paddled as a producer in
Hollywood a parody of a sportscasters
life called B skip lightning show and at
first I was going to be cast as skip
lightning and be in the opening sequence
skip lightning got out of a car in a
parking lot somewhere and a kid comes up
and asks for an autograph and skip
Lightning signs the autograph and as the
kid walks away turns around and yells
and says hey you know I thought you were
Dan Patrick though so we played off of
this thing before Jim good to catch up
with you and I'm sure we'll have part
three of this this tandem here coming up
soon thank you for joining us I'm not so
sure there will be a part three I I am
100%
everybody's saying that because of the
economic reality but I'm not a hundred
percent certain that triple G is gonna
want to do it again
we'll see thank you Jim all right you
later it's Jim Lampley he was on the
call of triple G and Canelo Alvarez I
don't know if you do a quick turnaround
here but I do think that boxing you look
at the future and Canelo's more the
future than triple G is triple G won the
first fight I think you could get a
consensus that he won the first fight I
thought he took the last round off I
thought it cost him I think it came down
to that that narrow over margin
obviously for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]